>> Sean: THANKS FOR JOINING US
TONIGHT.
I APPRECIATE IT.
JEFFREY EPSTEIN LOVER GHISLAINE
MAXWELL WAS FOUND GUILTY FOR HER
ROLE IN THE CHILD SEX
MY QUESTION FOR YOU, YOU
REPRESENT 50 OF THE VICTIMS.
ARE ANY OF YOUR CLIENTS GOING TO
NAME NAMES OF WHETHER OR NOT
THERE WAS ANYONE ELSE INVOLVED
OTHER THAN MAXWELL AND EPSTEIN?
>> ARE MY CLIENTS GOING TO NAME
OTHER PEOPLE?
YES, THAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
IT IT WOULD BE PREFERABLE IF
THOSE PEOPLE NOW WOULD COME
FORWARD AND GIVE US A CALL AND
TALK TO US.
AS WE HAVE SEEN BY THIS VERDICT,
IT'S NEVER TOO LATE TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
IT'S NEVER TOO LATE TO COME
FORWARD AND SHARE YOUR STORY IF
YOU ARE A VICTIM.
>> Sean: THAT'S TRUE.
FOR YOUR CLIENTS, THE 50 OF
THEM, WITH THIS VERDICT DO THEY
FEEL THERE WAS SOME KIND OF
JUSTICE SERVED?
THIS WAS LATE JUSTICE.
THIS CASE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
PROSECUTED A LONG TIME AGO.
DOES THIS VERDICT GIVE THEM SOME
KIND OF PEACE OF MIND?
>> THIS VERDICT DID A LOT FOR
THEM.
THE GOVERNMENT THE FIRST TIME
AROUND WITH THE JEFFREY EPSTEIN
CASE IN FLORIDA CAUSED THEM TO
LOSE CONFIDENCE IN THE SYSTEM
AND THE GOVERNMENT.
THIS WENT A LONG WAY TOWARDS
RESURRECTING THAT LOST TRUST.
ONE OF MY CLIENTS SAID WE
FINALLY FEEL LIKE WE MATTER.
THAT'S A REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT
STATEMENT.
IT'S CONSISTENT THROUGHOUT THE
20 OR MORE CLIENTS I HAD
A CHANCE TO SPEAK TO SINCE THE
VIRGINIA TECHED  -- VERDICT CAME
OUT.
>> Sean: THERE IS SPECULATION
GHISLAINE MAXWELL MAY EXPOSE
PEOPLE AS WELL.
SOME MAY BE WEALTHY AND MAYBE
ROYALS.
DO YOU THINK SHE WILL EXPOSE WHO
WAS INVOLVED IN THIS SEX RING?
>> WELL, GHISLAINE MAXWELL HAD
A CHANCE FOR THE LAST 10 YEARS
TO TELL ALL.
THERE WAS A TIME WHERE SHE COULD
HAVE RATTED OUT JEFFREY EPSTEIN
AND DIDN'T.
IT DOESN'T SEEM TO ME SHE WILL
TUN RAT NOW ESPECIALLY ON HER
GOOD FRIENDS -- SHE IS THE TOP
OF THE PYRAMID.
ANYBODY SHE RATS OUT IS LOW ON
THE RUNGS THAN SHE IS.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT WOULD CUT
DOWN OR SENTENCE EVEN IF SHE
WERE TO DO THAT.
>> Sean: I WAS A PROSECUTOR FOR
10 YEARS AND THESE CASES DESTROY
LITTLE GIRLS.
IT'S A CRIME THAT LASTS WITH
THEM FOR THEIR WHOLE LIFETIME.
I AM GRATEFUL YOU REPRESENTED 50
OTHER YOUNG WOMEN WHO HAD THIS
HAPPEN TO THEM.
HOW ARE THEY DOING?
ARE THEY PUTTING THEIR LIVES
TOGETHER RIGHT NOW?
>> WELL, HAVING BEEN A FORMER
PROSECUTOR IT'S NOT A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL.
SOME ARE DOING VERY WELL
CONSIDERING.
AS YOU MENTIONED, IT'S A LIFE
SENTENCE FOR MOST OF THEM.
IT'S NOT PAIN AND SUFFERING THAT
GOES AWAY EVEN WITH A VERDICT
LIKE THIS.
I ASKED ABOUT THE SENTENCE THAT
GHISLAINE MAXWELL WILL RECEIVE
WHICH WILL PROBABLY BE A LIFE
SENTENCE FOR HER.
CONSIDERING SHE WAS THE CAUSE OF
A LIFE SENTENCE OF PAIN AND
SUFFERING FOR DOZENS IF NOT
HUNDREDS OF YOUNG WOMEN, IT'S AS
CLOSE TO JUSTICE AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE.
SOME OF MY CLIENTS ARE DO WELL
AND SOME